quand une partie d'échec se transforme
en un épisode de Game of Thrones ça
donne ça on est au championnat de France
2019 le roi blanc entame sa marche
triomphale après une série d'échec par
les fous noirs E4 échecs il continue sa
randonnée improvisée en F4 G5 échec roi
F5 il franchit le mur la garde de nuit
se met à trembler le roi poursuit sa
course infernale après une petite série
d'échecs venu bluffer tout ça roi G7 on
est au 24e coup le roi blanc a une case
de la ligne d'arrivée c'est quasiment du
jamais vu va s'en suivre une série
tactique extrêmement compliquée toutes
les pièces sont en prises on comprend
rien on sait pas pourquoi le roi a calé
au bord de la ligne d'arrivée quand le
roi noir sans hardis dit qu'il a
peut-être une chance de gagner la course
on n'est pas malheureusement pour lui
dans la FAB du lièvre et de la tortue il
va être contraint de reculer il va se
faire mater grâce au roi blanc héroï qui
vient décapiter son homologue en
contrôlant toutes ses cases de fit